Okay, a little more,
Bach
Yes, if you
win unilaterally, you'll be able to improve as soon as you win.
That's not Akira-kun, he's from the Touhou team He's
playing games He's playing
Hooper in the classroom Even during class and
break time, he's always top class in national tests
You're
getting good grades
Official grammar
vocabulary  Or that's
all, you're a weirdo at home
, even if you think that way, the
exam war is neither a war nor a competition
That car can't get serious You
can endure various themes, you can't
clear enemies and obstacles
That's why it's an ordinary day o For
me it's a
typhoon  The
condition for defeat is to get caught What about
my
bonus?  It
takes a long time to come up
.
tan
Can you still move Go for the
win His jumping ability
will try to jump over it Naturally Nail Yes Yes Yes
If you can make predictions and prepare, you can clear the game
Congratulations Shoraku Shiratani
No way I can repel my pet Navi
See you later  Moonlight Dry Kick
It's time to take notes from this woman's hits
.
Hey, my grandfather is in, it's
not game over,
next time I want to play a nine-shot
game
A game to forget the boring daily life
[Applause]
Tatan
[Music]
[Applause]
par
[Music]
[Applause]
ja ran
[Music]
4 days
right?
That's right, dancing is
also accompanied by
tande
me
Your navigator, after all, I'll do my best
Symptom
Nyan
[Music]
Ah, that's
[Music] It
was selected as a monitor for our project.
Let me explain
Kita
, everyone here now doesn't always have a family register
.
No
two, stop
playing pranks on movie flights
Thank you for helping me with seaweed and kelp
Oh
ni Retirement penetrating magic As you
can see, I have the ability to buy hands
And in fact,
I want to open up an argumentative ability to everyone here  In other
words, you will be asked
to participate as test
monitors for your abilities
.
In that
case, you will be asked to leave the venue, so please act diligently
. Next, I will explain the basic rules.
You will also be able to use abilities.
Next, even if you kill or injure a monitor with the ability Io permission,
you won't be
penalized.
Because of Miyazaki 7 Tower's
extension,
I won't take the initiative to leave the house like I did with malic acid Papo
Madoka the Ripper,
you're such a mischievous kind of oily
book
10 questions, a question with a
chopped scene.
easy to stop without
I don't want to make a promise to my sister, she's a very nice person.
Isn't it the
store's mission
?  It's boring The
answer is my wife
You were chosen by
chance me
On the contrary, I feel comfortable Winning the car lottery
Or o
ah ah ah
Ideas are about to bloom It's
already that time So why
don't we mix the question time here  The first
program is a doggie with a simple pedigree.I
won't show you to your room from now on.It
would be nice to check your abilities and practice there.
There are many other
things I'm curious about, but
what's more important than now
is what my abilities are.
No,
uh,
what do you say, it's a
musical instrument,
well, are you a dull boy?
Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha, the
current situation is too unnatural for the top plate.
The
stories and rules that we were told, that
woman was guiding us to Porothief from the beginning
What is an experiment monitor for abilities It's
interesting
, I'll try it seriously  It's
finally
here, they're all set this time, they'll soon find
out,
too.
i hated it
Oh, I'm not good at the class
just now,
but it can't be helped. You surrender as soon
as the match starts.
And
ee 9 branches Well, I
'll return the first program from this I'll declare defeat If one of them
faints and faints, I
'll be scared 2 Well then, it
's a signal to prepare the venue.
Afterwards it's a battle Even though
people played a central role in the earthquake
See me Shingo Kyun Chara Bi
Good
def
masu dero
Rally and listen name
i can you do maker navi g It's
hard work
Well it's over
It's
not good yet, so
it's
a bargain, isn't it
?  Come on,
this is the last time I guess
I'm running out of ideas Hey,
if I could, I would have killed a friend who was in the same situation
.
Ah,
my ability is too dangerous, so I
was hesitant to use
it.  Hmmm,
my ability
is the ability to turn my hand to the side
here
[music]
yeah yeah yeah looks like a mask
yeah yeah The
ability to turn my body to the side
Will Kyun go back to being a book stick? This time it's my turn to say
There shouldn't be any chances of winning if I lose my weapon.
] It's
amazing that everyone
used their abilities so well on this day
But why did
n't they use their
abilities until the very last minute?  I thought it was
It was an interesting illusion
Akira-kun said that my abilities were strong
, but that
was a lie.
It's your opponent, the ability that I thought was your
ability So the timing to tell your opponent and the
situation that makes you want to believe is
Nikko  To
my sales
This time it went well This time
it's still a verification with this ability It's different
The content of the game is also a slave ability, and in
that respect this ability is interesting
First of all, go as they wish.
You know, this time you'll make me regret giving me the ability The
game has just begun
yeah yeah yeah
[music] Kusashida dna [music]
sugar
[music] It's
something I can do backwards
aname
dee
[music]
nan
already a key
[MUSIC]
Buhn and Yang's next meeting and each viewing
Thank you for watching
.
The witches of the witches
Strengthen the three consecutive holidays and
enter the office at 2:02 Don't worry about whether you can make a single note of the teacher
What kind of training is it?
Look forward to